التقط عالم إيطالي هذه
الصورة لجزء من
الصاروخ الصيني في السماء فوق إيطاليا
، ومن المتوقع أن يدخل
الغلاف الجوي للأرض مرة أخرى في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع.
إيشي أوكاكو
عالم فيزياء نظرية في
جامعة مدينة نيويورك ومؤلف
كتاب جديد يسمى معادلة
الإله ، البحث عن نظرية لكل شيء ،
وهو أستاذ في نيويورك تايمز الأكثر مبيعًا ،
إنه لأمر رائع أن أراك أعني إلى أي مدى
يجب أن نكون قلقين هذا 20-  طن
من الصاروخ جيدًا مثل الخفافيش خارج
الصحة ،
هذا الصاروخ الثالث والعشرون للصاروخ الصيني طويل
المسيرة
5b يخرج عن نطاق السيطرة
ويمكن أن يضرب في أي مكان أقصى الشمال
مثل مدينة نيويورك
أو أقصى الجنوب مثل نيوزيلندا التي
تضيقه لأسفل
نعم  وهذا جزء كبير من
سطح الأرض الآن من المحتمل
أن تهبط بشكل غير ضار في المحيط
ولكن هناك فرصة محدودة
حتى أنها قد تهبط هنا في
المقر الرئيسي لـ CNN  فوق رؤوسنا ،
نحن ببساطة لا نعرف إلى أين
سيهبط الناس ويجدون صعوبة في
فهم أنه
لا توجد فرصة تقريبًا على الإطلاق ولكنها
ليست صفرية ولا تسافر بسرعة 18000
ميل في الساعة
مثل نيزك ملتهب من الفضاء
الخارجي سوف يضيء السماء